températures glaciales neige le port du
bonnet sera-t-il obligatoire dans les
prochains jours nous allons poser toutes
ces questions au centre météorologique
est ici à trappes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
ab côté emmanuel vers prévisionnistes
ici au centre météo france emmanuel est
ce que ça va perdurer cette vague de
froid alors encore jusqu'à demain on
attend des températures relativement
basses même très basses qui descendront
dans la nuit prochaine de nouveaux
verres moins six à moins 9 degrés et
avec le vent ça fera une sensation
encore plus froides et des températures
ressenties de l'an de -10 à moins 12
mois 13 ou au moins 14 degrés suivant
l'intensité du vent
ensuite on attend un radoucissement
progressif au cours de la journée de
jeudi et surtout à partir de vendredi et
le week-end prochain
est ce que c'est un phénomène
exceptionnel alors qu'on vit en ce
moment pour l'hiver non c'est pas
exceptionnel mais c'est vrai que ça
arrive pas tous les ans ce genre de
périodes de froid aussi intense
là c'est vrai que depuis plusieurs jours
on a des températures qui sont très
inférieures aux normales de saison
surtout depuis lundi et on a atteint un
minimum dans la nuit dernière avec des
températures qui était déjà proche de
moins six à moins huit degrés un peu
partout sur le département
et ça devrait se reproduire dans l'année
prochaine c'est un phénomène qui se voit
une fois tous les dix ans on peut dire
la d1 fois c'était en mars 2005
alors effectivement on mars 2005
on avait eu une période de froid entre
guillemets un peu tardive et intense
là ça se produit fin février et tous les
dix ans et pas forcément régulier mais
ça se reproduit régulièrement comment on
fait pour prévenir ce type de
rendez-vous avec le froid alors pour
prévenir ou pour prévoir donc pour
prévoir ce genre d'événement mais on a
des modèles de prévision numérique qui
nous donne l'évolution du temps pour les
dix jours qui viennent voir un peu plus
loin si on veut mais plus on essaie de
voir loin dans le temps et moins les
prévisions sont précises et il ya
également un épisode neigeux qui
s'annonce jeudi alors effectivement on a
un épisode neigeux qui devrait mettre un
terme à cette vague de froid et qui est
attendu à partir de la nuit de
mercredi à jeudi et jeudi dans la
matinée ou en cours de cette matinée la
neige devrait être progressivement
remplacés par de la pluie prix
verglaçantes dans un premier temps et
puis à priori à partir de la mi journée
dans l'après midi on devrait avoir de la
pluie seul qui ne verrait glace plus et
donc ne provoque plus de phénomènes
glissants
ls va t elle tenir sur les routes la
neige va tenir dans la nuit de mercredi
à jeudi puisque les températures seront
encore très froide et les sols seront
gelés jeudi matin on aura encore
certainement une tenue au sol puisque
les températures resteront négatives et
ce qui sera à surveiller surtout jeudi
matin ce sera le passage en pluie
verglaçante
killa pourront donner des sols très
glissants
est ce qu'on pourra enlever le beau et
élégant pour ce week-end alors pensé
week-end oui normalement on devrait plus
avoir de geler des températures
positives du matin jusqu'au soir
donc à partir la semaine prochaine on
peut dire que c'est bon alors même à
partir de vendredi est plus tôt samedi
on va retrouver des températures de
saison qui évolueront en gros entre 2 et
10 degrés et du coup au mois de mars
sera
un début de mois de mars dans les normes
de saison au niveau des températures
merci manuel vert plus d'informations
sur le site météo france points comme le
froid devrait persister encore pendant
deux jours